nabil car we and a Syed faced off in a
debate a rare event in the Arab world
and a moment of pride for the Tunisians
who eight years ago inspired the
pro-democracy movement also known as the
Arab Spring the debate was a crucial
moment for the two candidates the
election divided Tunisians
seculars and liberals back karui while
conservatives leftists and nationalists
endorse i yet cutlasses i was leading in
the parliamentary and presidential
elections and it makes him into jail
despite that I still moved on to the
second round
my opponents thought I'd be defeated
Tunisians are free they will never
return to the cage and won't accept
being given crumbs they are free and
already committed to building a new
country
supporters of Nabil car we are jubilant
their leader and media mogul was
released from jail and is back on the
campaign trained by the man in his party
have only a limited time to convince
people that he is the right person to
leave the country Paris party heart of
Tunisia which he founded three months
ago came in second in the parliamentary
election becoming the second largest
political party after the conservative
and nada from the beginning of the
campaign how his rival Isis I yet kept a
low profile of his supporters took to
the streets promoting the man they say
will end corruption and you know the
people but people are frustrated with
their leaders eight years after the
Revolution they see little change in
their country and their expectations are
high and have Dima our president should
make young people more of a priority as
far as I'm concerned I have no faith in
the political elite we want a president
who stands for all Tunisians we are
defied a country that has different
political parties social classes we
don't want a president defending a
particular class or group after the 2011
revolution the president lost many
powers to both the Prime Minister and
Parliament but the president retained
control of defense and foreign affairs
for many Tunisians the president is more
than just a symbol
the recent parliamentary elections have
resulted in a divided Parliament and the
lead party may not be able to form a
governing coalition this is where the
next president is expected to step in to
end the political impasse Havana al
Jazeera Tunis